thanks so much for having me I'm excited
to have this opportunity to share with
you my work and I wanted to make a
little apology I somehow thought they
were going to be more professors and
less students in the room and so let me
just say what that's going to mean and
how I structured my talk I think your
students are you'll be fine but the
first half of it is really me asking
this question for professors about how
it is that we might and in what ways we
might engage across those who are
artists working artists and professors
those who are scholars and those of us
who are activists in relationship to our
pedagogy and that might be a little less
interesting to you although I think if
as people who are being trained in these
traditions i hope you'll sort of think
about what it means for your own
schooling and then the second half of
the talk i'll be showing this youtube
project which i think will be will be i
hope will be relevant for everybody and
thinking about the ways in which it
allows all of those interests of mind to
come together so let's see if i can
close it okay today i will focus upon
praxis reflects it reflecting upon how i
wrangled with this idea method and
orientation in my most recent
publication and again it that that words
in scare quotes scare quotes because
it's not yet clear what it means to put
a website up on a presses website that
never have a book a significant online
effort currently under contract
negotiations with MIT press a work that
brings together my abundant writings
about a course that i taught about and
also on youtube in 2007 and 2008 i will
engage in a full description of this
project the teaching project and it's
praxis after setting up some defining
terms for me praxis is the difficult but
necessary work of bringing bridging
ideas particularly history and theory
with the production of things
particularly media objects like videos
films or websites driven by the
compulsion to change
change encompass a does material goals
and their associated actions is what
truly initiates and confirms praxis one
really need not engage in praxis the
difficult and usually unsupported work
of unmaking and relinking disciplines
institutional boundaries and protocols
unless one begins from the commitment to
attempt to amend something in the world
alternatively if one starts a project
with world or self changing in mind what
material n do I hope to accomplish with
this work and why I find it hard to
believe that one would not engage in
praxis as the objects most activists
need to achieve their specific goals are
refined or even made viable through a
formulating and polishing with the wax
and wane of history and theory now of
course I'm talking here specifically
about praxis in the Academy and clearly
hear the paralyzing grip of disciplinary
specificity professional training and
institutional evaluation function quite
effectively to keep most of us from ever
even trying and here thinking up in
artists are trained in one way people
getting PhDs in English or trained
another our schooling confirms that we
are really not authorized to are even
capable of asking world-changing
questions from this birth and even when
we do we remain best supportive to
either think and then write about the
activist things that other people make
or make things that others will think
and write about politically certainly
there are some academic institutions the
better support practices including my
sixties hippie hippie college pitzer and
I think an other time it would be very
interesting to talk about the kinds of
support people need to do politically
engaged making and theorizing and it
pits are a founding commitment from the
60s to breaking down disciplines while
expanding real world engagement sees my
activists work as admirable not ants and
sillery I'm actually encouraged to have
world bound goals for instance I want to
contribute to conversations about ending
the war in Iraq by looking at how
debates within the left or for
shortening our abilities to better
engage the right reflections about this
limitation on the left might lead to new
oppositional strategies this goal begs
the necks against
can question along the Praxis chain who
in particular do I want to converse
together and even more specifically how
where when and towards what end unlike
when I engage in a more typical academic
or art project not praxis where I raised
and then answer for an audience much
like me a unique and small variation
upon a question with which we are all
already familiar in my praxis work the
question of audience itself and then
those immediately following about form
and method must be modified even
tailor-made to best suit the very
particular goals I begin with our
disciplines worked effectively missing
word our disciplines work effectively
because of their prescribed and known
audience method form vernacular and
rationale and each of these must be self
consciously thought out for every work
of praxis while so much of our academic
and artistic effort is streamlined
through accepted disciplinary rubrics
histories and qualities of expertise
training and evaluation praxis is
self-defined and self aware of its own
forms and functions now I would I could
certainly address my stated
world-changing goal altering the
conversation about leftist
interpretations of the Iraq war so as to
change our activism by writing a
theoretical piece about the
representation of the Iraq war for a
Media Studies journal but clearly this
is needed the best form or the best
suited audience for my goals although it
would undoubtedly not hurt if I
responded in such a limited fashion
however I want to reach educated
leftists and most live outside the
accounting or even media studies for
that matter and I don't want to be
either pigeon-holed or confined by my
experts Cinema Studies discourse and a
lot of my thinking about this has to do
with the very specific vernaculars we
use in different context what happens
when we begin to move across media forum
how do we do we have to speak in a
different language that's I chose to
make it for this project a documentary a
feature-length documentary called scale
measuring right in the media age about
it with my activist sister Antonia yuhas
that I intended for international film
festivals college classrooms and
activist work
groups to play on the internet and to be
part of an organized effort to situate
these questions into a larger fabric of
anti-war organizing and conversation
many of our efforts with annika within
the academy then will or will not be
praxis depending upon these two key
interrelated features their political
intention and reflexive structure for
instance scholarly writing documentary
painting teaching game design kandak and
praxis if and when the needs of our
political ends force us to rethink and
then retool our inherited forms and
operating procedures and interestingly
many of us first perhaps tentatively
began to do this or are doing this newly
again as we find ourselves moving our
practices online because there we are
suddenly given leeway and even licensed
over audience who's going to read our
work form what you know we can define
the form that it takes and most
critically intent often denied us in the
more regulated and ossified forms of our
home disciplines and institutions which
gets me at last to YouTube
or it's also inception this is everybody
is making writing and teaching
artists and we're so many nights when
I'm connects my project
I rather marvelous
and cyber made most of this project also
remained relatively stable to create a
really critical educated analysis of the
state
the very night vision constraints and
power that form and stable production
and reception and that criticism
available to users of the site
so they can better practice and it gave
me
I'm sorry it was these schools
praxis initiative variety
just about these ones the focus of
remainder of his talk sure I wrote some
additional academic papers published on
paper but Christian that's a stupid
hypothetical particle I'm i can bring
Constitution it up for these be
enhancing endeavors lot hurting animals
poultry steps that way
software
today I'm focus on six farming practices
that arise
form as it english this a person with
body of work the videos
charlestown samosas
look make it useless
support us
literacy foundation grant examples of
that special square practice
early stop obvious first draft of this
publication to show and explain how to
collaboration the designer programmer
Craig future we tried to creating
practices best suited to form the
to my questions that I want house
before I begin my examination of praxis
in this work and this is the
introduction to the work the book
whatever it is I'd like to quickly
highlight three opaque and reasoned
routes that this publication uses to
structure its many and diverse critical
writings about YouTube and you know this
is not an introduction to this book so
you'll just sort of have to pick things
up as I go but there are 10 you tours
which also you can see down here and
then all the media there are 200 pieces
of information they're tagged with 20
tags practice being one of them and that
is how I organize what I call its text
eoz and text eoz our text plus video
so now we're inside my publication text
eoz are the building blocks of the site
and these architectural wonders allow
online media scholars like myself to
link text and video into discrete
interactive multimodal blocks of media
writing my texteas are then tagged with
20 possible terms to follow them is to
engage with a more random yet highly
structured view of my analysis so you
see here I'm talking about practice
today so that will just randomly link
you to something that's called praxis
and unfortunately when it goes on to the
big screen this should just sit on one
screen it's not working very well but
you can see that this is a tech CEO
about revolutionary cinema and it should
it would on a desk on a laptop it shows
as on your screen praxis is one of my 20
tags
so now you're seeing all of the techs
toews that are about practices to
organize this talk about practice in my
youtube work I looked at the 33 texteas
that I so tagged and asked what were the
distinct if related ideas about praxis
that were displayed across this varied
body of work by showing you examples of
each praxis type I hope you will also
observe some of the formal answers we
have been inventing to best express our
stated praxis goals of empowering
YouTube users to make more critical
media I find that I tagged texteas with
the term praxis if they did one of six
things one they make their political and
theoretical argument through a YouTube
video too they integrate theory practice
and politics onto one page three they
document and thus further teaching as a
form of praxis for they engage in
theorizing from the making of something
in the name of changing something else
five they attempt to create praxis
communities to better hold informed
discourse about social issues and
meaning making and six they display
praxis manifestos so the Ranger of the
talk i'm going to show you those six
forms of praxis and i hope you'll get a
sense of the larger piece just by sort
of watching at work so this is video as
praxis at its most streamlined
theoretical argumentation occurs in my
project through video alone a form of
praxis that is especially politicized
when it is my students who are given
authority to create the earliest theory
about youtube on its pages and through
its forms
buyers goes into written text as opposed
to a
video is very hard to come across be
sincere and do not edit yourself up on
it is a performance
was out there and so they rebuild at war
something across them just a message
where the text-based ranch in different
ways but it is what it is where as you
know video for your support on this
right here in just under look simply
talking aquarium setting urine
is our plays an important goal
well first community
for commercial or scale
prepared even in modern and contemporary
art history or something
explode and become more than itself
before broken down and naturally I think
it was a story where it has you know
jump the shark and now something else to
do all of this content democratic for
the local time so my question is where
are we going how do we get that oil
some was made at the very beginning of
the class and part of what she's asking
that is because it was not clear what we
were doing in the class the architecture
of the project and this is an example of
praxis as integration the architecture
the project let them use texteas as
montage units that allow theory practice
and politics to speak against alongside
and in tandem
let us say elevator bacana public
actually
the I'm good
forgive the city of him
they rule they are happy be a modern
behalf
the High Sierra and definitely here
I keep that is going to save me rope and
a recipe my dad really rocks to wrestle
with countries ago okay so I mean you
should be able to see this all at once
so you're getting that this is a
ludicrous pond and the idea of here is
it gone and the way in which people are
not yet using this in a particular
transformative way sort of all put on 21
and I'm sorry you can sort of see them
all the same time you're supposed to
this is what I call a slogan on in the
language of the writing that I'm engaged
with here at XTO where video rep and
writing hold equal weight on the page
visually in the construction of the
argument and in their dialogue this
texty texty o holds at least six voices
together conversing about while making
theory Godard speaking Godard writing
here his theory the filmmaker who
interviews Godard Sean Christian the
maker of the rap rap my written voice
and my voice as an editor the next page
is an example of teaching as praxis many
professors are moving their media
studies new media pedagogy and criticism
online into a politicized praxis where
media making in theory align in this
slogan I allow competing teachings to be
softened by the soothing strain of a
haunting movie score
of course is produced the signature
style to the video blog now whatever
eyes that's form is the bad quality of
the video in the sense that these videos
are entirely dependent that what the
image looks like really is in
significance of power
they tend to be important the most
sincere apologies lots of cameras
computer you're an entity
all of this doesn't matter because they
created a front of expression where I
just lead directly to you about my
knowledge and feelings usually as a
normal person get in a society that is
one signature
is the perfect for the quarterback video
is the dynasty it's a venue that's made
by three uses for refers to mainstream
America so it's characterized by really
high production values things if I
professionals that tension came around
very quickly organized by
and before that you're popular culture
and not visual in my tortured it now one
of the things about my book Quinn code
whatever it is it goes off of itself
that's anything them a lot on line can
do
vernacular is a fancy word for informal
when local languages like Italian and
French broke away from Latin which
remained a formal liturgical language
they were called vernaculars and going
to video vernacular refers to the
emergence of millions and video
producers and as an informal even
conversational genre of video production
justice Scrabble text and scribe
illiteracy okay so obviously two
opposing understandings of how
vernacular of videos functioning they're
both true i think describing
different
different applications and different we
come from very different places
number four theorizing as praxis in this
more text heavy textio where video works
to support or demonstrate my written
argument and so you'll see there's a lot
more text here and as you scroll down
the text videos sort of a line with
various parts of the argument I self
reflexively theorized about making this
work by way of a list you skate things
on my list I found that online writing
functions best when little or ideally no
scrolling if needed the computer is
essentially a distraction to illustrate
solicitor people's attention span online
is different from when they read a book
or watch a video for that matter IV
right through montage that distraction
is definitive universities they do stuff
to do it's like a Swiss Army knife they
never stopped expanding runs out this
one book the three things this don't
booked us for dinner to join Kappa okay
Peter does nothing the problem is when
you really need to hook her down it's
work done then it's like trying to write
a novel on a typewriter to the census
pornography yeah the eye chart inner
tension would look like this while using
the computer looks like this people the
only solution is to free ourselves from
the tyranny of computers needs protect
our my fifth idea about practice on my
site is about perhapses communities
working online writing allows for the
creation of praxis communities of
like-minded professionals working
alright so I'm going to take you guys
back 25 years to start off now take it
back to nineteen eighty-four to nineteen
eighty-four Neil postman a New Yorker
we're sitting in New York thinking about
the book 1984 and he started to think
that no one well we envision had not
come true in the United States except
the Huxley inversion may be had well
around the inversion was this vision the
language you know the big brothers say
control basically taking taking over
everything that's the inversion was one
in which we have basically abuse
ourselves to death being the old Roman
version although feared that the fear of
those people group in this case my
writing takes michael wesch who's a
sociologist and youtube booster self
reflexively to task about his rosy
theories and practices of community so
in his in his lecture he's going to use
free he uses for you
you
I find Michael wish to be very not very
romantic I have to say so you know I I
suggest you look here to see to see more
radical forms of media network let me
make sure I turn myself
whoop step on the wrong with a tie I'm
sorry I'm a mad person I'm just having
up slightly hard time using them in her
face okay that's not what I want to
interrupt
where's my next tag
my sixth form of praxis in my own
project is what I call praxis manifestos
I will conclude today with the sixth
form the aunt of praxis the online
production and dissemination of practice
manifestos what this Tom what this talk
already is in that my praxis project
today had the real world political bowl
of both modeling for and engaging in
conversation with artists and scholars
in the Academy about the possibility for
politically motivated theoretical
practice and what it will become
tomorrow once it's videotape version
gets put on YouTube they're critically
speaking to a larger more diverse
audience of users and makers together
creating the possibilities for a
learning community that's not inside of
this room about the praxis the praxis
possibilities of social media and so
here you see ten ideas about praxis and
then three ideas three calls to action
I'll end with the last one
you're watching the second part filming
section of the witness side video
advocacy it comes how to film a powerful
interview how to get the right footed
she there with it and how to be taken
people you phone people tell sir Maurice
let people speak okay I'll end with that
i will say that because i was focusing
on practice for the talk i didn't get to
show you a lot of the really amazing and
fun and funny videos that my students
have made and that i found as well so i
hope at some point you'll get a chance
to them go into the site and look around
there's hundreds of examples of them my
students theorized in all of these ideas
about YouTube and other people as well
like geriatric 1970 feel whatever it is
English but that's that's all for today
thank you